- [John] The Outer
Banks, paradise on Earth.
(smooth lilting music)
- Maybe you'll get a real edit soon.
You know?
(static hissing)
- What's up, everybody.
- Today, we're gonna be
watching some Outer Banks
- fan content
- and reacting to them.
- This is "Scene Stealers".
(upbeat music)
(static hissing)
- I feel like I'm dead.
(Madelyn gasps)
(gentle solemn music)
I'm alive, but I'm dead.
(static hissing)
(Chase laughing)
- Hold up, wait.
What?
- You're not wrong.
- This summarizes our show. (laughs)
- It's so on-brand.
- I think I was dead for three minutes.
(gentle upbeat music)
- That's a great skit.
Good job.
(static hissing)
- Everything you do is for yourself.
You are greedy.
You are selfish.
You are manipulative.
You are a liar.
And you are a murderer.
(hand slaps)
- (gasps) Oh, she did the slap, too.
I'm in shock.
(static hissing)
Wow.
Who hurt you?
That was beautiful.
(static hissing)
- [John] The Outer
Banks, paradise on Earth.
And that's me, John Booker Routledge.
(smooth lilting music)
And this is where I live.
- Yeah, yeah.
That's how we hide.
(static hissing)
The acting, I mean, if you
want to take my job you should
because you fully deserve it, so...
(static hissing)
(smooth lilting music)
- Wow.
Wow.
I can't bake that.
I can cook, but I'm really not a baker,
and I definitely cannot bake that.
(static hissing)
- [John] The Outer
Banks, paradise on Earth.
(smooth lilting music)
(Madison laughing)
- [Madison] The commitment.
(static hissing)
I'm pretty sure I commented on this one.
I was like, "Wait."
This is, I'm gonna get what
I want one way or another.
Love this.
(static hissing)
(upbeat music)
- Oh wow.
Oh, that's sick.
(static hissing)
Yo!
That one right there, top notch.
Really good line work,
really good shading.
It's kind of weird
seeing yourself drawn out
'cause it's like what people
kind of think you look like
almost in a way.
But, that's spectacular.
(static hissing)
(smooth lilting music)
- I mean, John B. doesn't
wear short shorts.
But, for the most part, yeah.
(static hissing)
- John B., I don't know if
there'd be a tank top underneath.
Think John B. is a skin shower.
(smooth lilting music)
- Yep.
- I don't know if he can afford Ray-Bans,
but he would probably buy
the Dollar Store version.
(static hissing)
- JJ, it would probably
be cargo shorts or jorts.
(static hissing)
(smooth lilting music)
- Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I like this top, that's cute.
(static hissing)
(smooth lilting music)
- The amount of effort that
she put into each outfit
is money.
(static hissing)
(smooth lilting music)
It's super accurate.
The bracelets, you've got bracelets,
you've got the bandana,
you've got the button down.
(static hissing)
Even the sad eyes
because John B. goes
through so much stuff.
That's how he looks every time he hears
that he's either lost treasure
or his dad is still missing.
(static hissing)
- [John] The Outer
Banks, paradise on Earth.
(smooth lilting music)
- Like, "Oh, my girlfriend
wanted to do this
as a couple's costume."
(static hissing)
And also, props to whoever
put OBX on the gas can.
That's attention to detail.
(static hissing)
- To all you creators out there,
just keep doing your thing.
Keep creating.
If this is what you want to do
and this is what gets you hyped,
then keep on keeping on.
(static hissing)
- Watch Outer Banks now
streaming on Netflix.
(upbeat music)